well I wanted to talk to you because the
last time this is was a very funny thing
I was
talking to you I saw you around
Christmas time Liza and I see you and
we're hanging out
and we get dinner
and this really happened I'm telling you
about this trailer that I saw online
yeah and I'm someone who
um
if something grabs me it really grabs me
and I can't stop thinking about it and I
watched this trailer and then I watched
it again and again and I was showing it
to my kids uh and it's the trailer that
had gone viral called cocaine bear oh oh
yeah so I am talk to you and I go like
oh man this thing cocaine beer and you
went yeah and I went oh man I don't see
that and you went you do know that
that's my movie and I didn't know and I
was talking to you about cocaine bear
and it was so I mean I'm sorry I felt
like an idiot but also you could what's
nice about it is you could tell my
enthusiasm was genuine real yeah it was
real I was like oh my God because I
thought this is the best title for a
movie since Pootie Tang
like it's one of the best titles for a
movie it's an amazing title ever and uh
and I just because all you need to hear
is cocaine Bear yeah but then I I see
the trailer and I was like oh gee and
like everyone else who saw the trailer
like what the you get it's a big like
what they made that's real they made
this they allowed people to make a movie
called that and then
um I was very excited because they said
hey uh Elizabeth Banks is coming on the
podcast which I was very excited about
and they said you can check out cocaine
bear if you want I was like are you
kidding me
and they're like yeah no we'll give you
a link and you can watch it so Liza and
I watched it and uh I had a blast we had
an absolute blast and there are
so many sequences there I mean I was
there are so many sequences in the movie
that I kind of want to watch a few more
times and I don't want to give anything
away but uh we do we talk a few things
into it that I hope make people want to
see it twice like wait what was that
line that she said again what was that
thing that she did and you know it's
it's fantastic is all you need to know
is it's cocaine Bear yeah
um
my only disappointment is at the end the
bear doesn't become like a producer
that would have been really good ending
he's a very on the lot he's on the lot
he's a very and he's still doing a ton
of cocaine totally and it's occasionally
attacking like a tour van but other than
that
um but what was really nice about it was
I think doing
I think the combination the peanut
butter and jelly sandwich that is scary
and funny is
probably almost impossible to pull off
and you pulled it off it is scary and
funny thank you yeah that was the
challenge of it right like that was the
the tone and the script that I thought
oh if I get this right I think it can
hit and and but it yeah it's a fine line
to walk for sure because there are
moments where I don't there are times
where truly the bear is doing something
absolutely terrible to somebody and I'm
howling yeah I'm laughing and also
shrieking at the same time and you don't
want to hear me laugh and shriek at the
same time it's I won't I won't no you
don't you don't it's really good that I
saw this I'm glad you had that reaction
because I've I've only seen it with
audiences you know and seeing it with
audiences
it's pretty intense because I you know I
mean you'll have couples having
completely different reactions sitting
right next to each other like some that
are just like I you know and others that
are laughing like in the same moment you
know which is very fun to see yeah all
I'll say is there's a whole scene that
involves EMTs and an ambulance and it
plays out and I'm just like uh and and
it goes on for a while and it just keeps
ratcheting up to the point where I think
this can't get crazier crazier and then
it doubles yeah uh and um
uh and the other thing I really liked
about it is I
and we've talked about this before we
won't name names but there are movies
famously that star kids yeah that and
I'll say it's so tricky because some a
lot of times I watch movies with kids
and I don't like the kids yeah and I'm
in general
uh I I like children I really do oh
that's good okay I mean I root for them
because that's the future of the species
it's very controversial I don't want to
spend time with them but I'm told my own
children are lovely and I will meet them
one day but uh the the girl and the boy
uh who are Central to it are great and
and the boy is I think a real find he
just gets a lot more time yeah but he's
a real find and I liked him yeah he has
some great lines he's a he is a for sure
a um an audience favorite yeah I think
putting kids into adult scenarios too
like truly adult sceners is always to me
can be very funny right and the movie is
really about I really love making movies
about underdogs generally and I like
multiple POV I've made three films now
they all are like you know many
characters I've never just followed you
know Jack Reacher or something I don't
know right
um so the the notion that we could find
like kids to put into this scenario I
was like well you're never gonna have a
bigger Underdog but like anybody meeting
a bear that they don't know is high in
cooking right like I don't care if you
are Jack Reacher you are an underdog in
that scenario also I just love I I it
was so funny to me how much the bear
enjoys cocaine he really likes it
and and uh and then once he gets a taste
for it you know God help you if you have
some cocaine in your back pocket yeah uh
and um it's all based on a real story
well which I didn't know yeah and and
frankly partially based on this notion
so in real life let's just say the real
life bear OD'd big time on the cocaine
right so it's a good message to get out
to those kids yeah but I think the movie
is not pro drug by the way the movie is
very much like drugs is bad yeah it is
it is
um so I I feel like I stayed true to my
you know to that we're keeping it clean
for the kids yes in that regard
um but the real bear truly obviously
loved that I mean could not stop eating
it to the point where it's like the
necropsy on the bear you know was like
it's a heart exploded every organ inside
of its body the bear itself became a
good poster child for don't don't do
drugs correct it really did
um but I remember when I read that story
which was is about this drug Runner
Andrew Thornton
um who opens our film dropping these
drugs out of this airplane and then he
ends up in a whole other scenario uh but
basically that this bear was like
collateral damage in this you know
bizarre drug run scenario and the war on
drugs and and I just I remember feeling
deep sympathy sure despair like what the
like this that's so and so when I
read this script
I thought well this this is the Revenge
story for the bear yeah
the bear didn't want the bear didn't
call his dealer no and say get over here
the bear was like I mean you put these
drugs right in front of me I tasted them
they made me excited I needed more you
know and now so now in the movie we just
imagine well what if that bear ran into
a bunch of people you know it's and I I
I don't I don't think I'm giving
anything away when I say it's uh and you
learn this in the movie but I thought it
was a really cool distinction that uh
there's a real distinction between brown
bears yes and uh black bears yeah and
black bears are thought to be much less
worrisome yeah and they are they truly
are yeah we shouldn't create I don't
want to create like Jaws here like I
don't want everyone to be like I can't
be you can you can see a black bear yeah
and not totally lose your mind I mean
don't go close to wild animal do I
really have to say that out loud on the
right podcast and maybe don't give it a
lot of code don't give it cocaine yeah
no so but it was it what I there's a
thing in the movie where people make
assumptions about this black bear
because black bears are supposed to be
pretty harmless and they don't know the
what's the back story they don't know
what this what's in this bear system so
they're like I don't worry about it and
it's friendly yeah so
um I was yeah that's one of my that's
Jesse Tyler Ferguson's character is like
a like a Peta bear expert right like he
loves animals he calls them friends he
doesn't he's really funny and you know
what I when he first came on camera I
didn't recognize him thank you and uh
and and then uh lies is the one that
said oh my God and I was laughing and
thinking oh this guy's terrific because
he looks quite different yes and then uh
Liza said that's that's Jesse that's
Jesse Tyler Ferguson I was like oh my
God yeah he's great he's so great we've
been old friends we I made one of my I
think my second movie ever I made with
Jesse in Vermont font in the late 90s
and he actually played a an anti
gay priest or like Seminary Student or
something yeah which is obviously
clearly not his life since he's married
to a man with children he changed a lot
he he saw I don't know yeah I saw the
light I was really Testament to his
acting skills yeah Conan because he
really played that up
um how excited were you when it's
Christmas time and the trailer hits and
people were freaking out and it's
blowing up was that is that a fun
experience well I mean I would think it
would have to think you go like oh thank
God you know you just are so relieved I
would say I was relieved more than
anything and I don't know I also know
I'm like I I still have to translate
into people buying tickets and putting
their butt in the seat and I don't know
if that I don't know what's happening in
the world anymore it's crazy I mean it's
a crazy time yeah uh with with streaming
and getting people into movie theaters
and everyone's trying to figure out the
business but I think all you
there's too much to worry about and all
you in my life what I'm constantly
reminding myself is
uh just worry about the work yeah and
then worry about what you can control
and then things change there's giant
tectonic shifts happening all around us
that we can't control yeah but uh I
think you've got a really good head
start with cocaine bear
[Laughter]
well I'm very glad that you enjoyed it
yeah and just the two of you snuggled up
in your house there was no snuggling
Eliza called a halt to that years ago